Florida Governor Ron DeSantis has just
launched
a heinous
incomprehensible attack
on children's right to learn about weird
queer Theory sex stuff in a in a black
studies course and ideologically
left-wing activist course in high school
can you imagine
this course on black history what are
one what's one of the lessons about
queer Theory now who would say that an
important part of black history is queer
theory that is somebody pushing an
agenda on our kids and so when you look
to see they have stuff about
intersectionality abolishing prisons
that's a political agenda and so we're
on that's the wrong side of the line for
Florida standards we believe in teaching
kids facts and how to think but we don't
believe they should have an agenda
imposed on them when you try to use
black history to shoehorn in queer
Theory you are clearly trying to use
that for political purposes
Ron DeSantis is doing exactly the right
thing here this is great that he is
Banning this black studies course
frankly even if it weren't teaching
queer Theory as part of it he still
should have banned the course because
black studies African-American studies
it's not just a regular old history
course
it's not a regular old cultural history
or military history or any serious study
of history it is a derivation of
critical theory and it is essentially
just leftist radical political activism
that's true of pretty much all of the
studies departments all of the gay
studies women's studies
black studies all of the studies
departments that cropped up in the
second half of the 20th century they're
just radical leftism okay and they're
academically not rigorous at all and
they poison people's minds and turns
their brains to soup so it's good that
this is being kicked out of the high
schools
however
[Music]
the argument that Ron DeSantis is making
here is not totally right it might be
politically effective so I don't
begrudge him that but it's not totally
right
now one thing that's great Rhonda Santos
used to say we don't want to teach
students what to think only how to think
and you'll notice in that speech there
because I I have
tried to correct that point a little bit
before and I think some other
conservatives may have too and you
notice he changed it a little bit he
said we wanted to teach students facts
and how to think that's an important
correction because if that's not the
same as saying we want to teach them how
to think not what to think when you say
we want to teach students facts you're
saying we do want to teach students what
to think and by teaching students what
to think about certain facts about
certain things then we are thereby
teaching the students how to think
but the point that DeSantis made is
all of this is what education is about
education is not about pushing a
political agenda and in fact DeSantis
when he posted that clip he tweeted that
as well he said this isn't we do not
think that education should be about
pushing a political agenda
that might be an effective piece of
political rhetoric but it isn't true
and we should we should all at least be
aware that education is in fact about
pushing a political agenda that is the
point of public education
public and political mean the exact same
thing
political is another word for public
it's the stuff that we all do together
not in our little private lives not in
the recesses of our own mind but
together
so when when DeSantis says education is
about pursuing truth not about a
political agenda he's half right it is
about pursuing truth but it is also
about applying those truths to the
political situation education is about
creating citizens education is about
inculcating a Civic spirit in people
education is about creating the next
generation of Americans who are going to
build up our country and live together
education is how we are raised and the
question of how we are raised and how we
behave and what we believe and how we
view our fellow countrymen and how we
view our country that is a deeply
political question
so the it is perfectly right and just to
ban black studies or whatever other
critical theory derived courses that
have somehow seeped their way like a
gaseous poison into High School
classrooms it is perfectly good to ban
them for political reasons they teach
things that are not true
and also they have poisonous political
effects and the only reason that the
libs want to put those courses into the
High School classrooms is because they
know that education is political the
libs are are right about so many things
at least in the abstract they get a lot
of things right in the abstract they get
they get pretty much all those things
wrong in practice when you get into the
specifics and into the substance but in
terms of the abstract and the procedure
in the form they tend to get these
things right they recognize that there's
no such thing as total Free Speech they
recognize that all state cultures have
standards and Norms conservatives
pretended that that wasn't the case for
the last 50 years that's how we lost our
American notion of free speech the libs
know that education is political
the conservatives pretended it's not
political that's how conservatives lost
the entire educational apparatus in
America
the the libs they're very crafty they're
very clever they have terrible
prescriptions for America and for other
countries as well but but they are
clever about how politics works and so
I think DeSantis is doing a great job I
don't even begrudge him his
slightly imprecise political rhetoric
here but at the very least we
conservatives we people who are
applauding the Santos in this phenomenal
action we should not be deceived he's
not trying to deceive us but we should
not deceive ourselves
education is political it is good that
it is political we should pursue
political ends that are conducive to to
truth and Justice not that they're
antithetical to those things they are
they go perfectly along with truth and
justice but we should pursue those
things in the classroom because if we
don't do it somebody else will and if
it's the libs who are pursuing their
political agenda in the classroom I
promise you it is not going to to go
along with truth and Justice and
certainly not with the American way the
lives are Furious about what DeSantis is
doing kjp Kareem Jean-Pierre the White
House Press Secretary says the move is
incomprehensible
these types of actions aren't new they
are not new from from what we're seeing
especially from Florida sadly Florida
currently bans teachers from taking to
talking about who they are and who they
love as we've talked about many times
here in this briefing room they have
banned more books in schools and
libraries than almost every other state
in the country and let's not forget they
didn't ban they didn't block be more
clear I want to make sure I'm using the
right word here they didn't block AP
European History they didn't block our
music history they didn't block our art
history but the state chooses to to
block a course that is meant for high
achieving high school students to learn
about their history of arts and culture
and it is uh you know it is uh
incomprehensible again and I will just
leave it there leave it there to make
your own uh to make your own
determination of why this occurred and
why this happened again it is not our
place to to direct or to to be involved
in any local school curriculum but this
is concerning oh it's not your place
okay then quiet
how about we just close that old Yap up
there at the White House Press breeding
room and listen it's after that 10
minute monologue I just launched into I
just want to make clear it's not my
place to to weigh in on this
but I'm going to continue to weigh in on
it as well incomprehensible the only
thing that's incomprehensible is the
course
and and the way that the libs are
portraying this that this is about
teaching the history of black people
it's not that's just a complete lie the
course includes books such as Kimberly
crenshaw's mapping the margins
intersectionality identity politics and
violence against women of color
that's not hey what did Frederick
Douglass do that is pushing a radical
Marxist
neo-marxist cultural Marxist whatever
term you want to use to describe the
20th century uh tradition of Western
Marxism that's what it's pushing okay
intersectionality the case for
reparations by Tony easycoats tanahisi
coats is a leftist pop writer he's not a
historian he is not a scholar he is not
someone who deserves even one second's
time in in a high school classroom he is
a radical and glib magazine essayist
there's a section on black queer studies
as Ron DeSantis said that is what is
incomprehensible and that is what is
going to muddle up students Minds
there's this idea in our society that we
need to have a totally open classroom
don't ban anything just be open to all
ideas well that's crazy you have to you
have to ban certain ideas you have to
leave them out of the curriculum there
are only so many weeks in a semester
every second that you waste reading Tony
easy coats and Kimberly Rancho is a
second that you're not reading a real
historian that you're not reading I
don't know Shakespeare that you're
you're not reading Tolstoy you're not
reading writers who are valuable who
will edify you and who will make you
more educated every every second that
you waste in a math classroom being
taught that two plus two equals five is
the second that you're not being taught
the truth which is that two plus two
equals four we have to ban two plus two
equals five out of the classroom
and we need to limit our curricula to
things that will actually educate
students and I promise you Kimberly
Crenshaw will not
hey the show continues now you don't
want to miss it become a member use code
Knowles Canada wlas at checkout for two
months free on all annual plans
we'll see you in the member block
[Music]